Aane 2 n Sonoji A
factory that draws after the expression of winning is spicy. Now
, use
it soothingly. It's a sweet flavor of bear meat.
Is a technique that is
the upper rank
of popping the onion.
By doing so, in addition to the garlic stuff, the amount of garlic that spreads and conveys the meat temporarily is
reduced.
The secret is honey and balsamic vinegar. Just let it go. The
foolish sweet and spicy sauce has a deep richness, and the acidity
squeezes the flavor tightly and gives it a beautiful
taste.
This scent is a
caramelize. It's an oxidation phenomenon that occurs when you heat the meat carefully. It's
an important technique that appears in various dishes from French dishes to sweets making.
First of all, heat it slowly and caramelize it, stretch it with balsamic vinegar, thicken it,
add the garlic and chopped onions and
sesame sauce that have been stored separately, and boil
it.  For example,
[Music]
Kuma Rikumen Chikatsu's share The best sauce for accelerating cars is completed.
Kuma meat is complemented with 8 heat material, and the barça is subtracted and coordinated with bones and caramel hands
. In other
words, I emphasize Kaori's subtraction.
I showed the opposite logic at the same time on this one dish.
Step is
a kind of foreign minister at the leader Senbatsu final. Hayama
[Music]